we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p here's an interesting
voicemail that came in this morning
hi david this is jeffrey from queens new
york again
you know i'm actually very nervous about
this election uh do you what do you
think the odds are that he's
disrupting some matter or some form uh
trump
because we'll never get a dictatorship
down democracy is dead
it's terrifying what democracy is dead
and i feel that my granddaughter
who found nine months old is going to
grow up in an entirely different country
than i did
goodbye and thanks for all your
reporting and
good luck they stay healthy
okay so but listen i get the frustration
we have a president
with dictatorial authoritarian
tendencies
and a sort of wish for that he's a
wannabe
um you are correct that many of the
democratic institutions of this country
are in crisis and they are in jeopardy
but to go further right now and to say
this is a dictatorship is is simply not
accurate i do think it's important
to be on the one hand warning people
about signs and symptoms but on the
other hand we don't want to be
hyperbolic but the frustration i'm with
you
we have an opportunity to do something
about it very soon let's actually do it
we've got a great bonus show planned for
you today we will talk about the
upcoming
rnc and dnc conventions and our plans
for coverage
we will talk about this maskless rally
of motorcyclists
in south dakota and much more get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming
members at joinpackman.com i'll see you
then